schauen wir auf die gamescom das ist ja
vom begeisterungslevel inzwischen wie
Fußballweltmeisterschaft zumindest bei
allen die unter 30 sind ja es ist die
größte gaming-messe der Welt sie findet
immer in Köln statt und da ist es
wirklich dich an Dich die Massen die
sich da durchwühlen um das neueste das
aktuellste auf dem Spielemarkt zu sehen
und auch zu testen vor allem es ist das
ganz ganz große daddeln und mittendrin
ist unsere bild-reporterin Kira Ortmann
mit ihren drei ultimativen Dattel
Highlights von der gamescom
Games Cosplays und in vier Tagen ca
300.000 Menschen auf der größten
gaming-messe der Welt die gamescom in
Köln
zu den Spiele-Highlights kommen wir
gleich zuerst die Show-Highlights der
Gamer
[Musik]
ihr seht es
ihr hinter uns und zwar ist hier live
Wrestling auf der Gamescom in diesem
Jahr definitiv eines der Highlights
das erste Mal birdling live zu sehen
hier auf der Gamescom also ich wusste es
vorher gar nicht einfach genial es macht
unglaublich viel Spaß
also ich finde es crazy weil ich habe
das Spiel angespielt und jetzt sieht man
ihn einfach auf der Bühne
sehr gut gemacht auf jeden Fall die
haben gut sie machen eine gute Show dort
in diesem Jahr in einer riesigen area
die Retro games
[Musik]
aber nicht nur die ganzen Neuheiten
begeistern die Leute hier auf der
Gamescom sondern auch die alten Spiele
ich bin hier nämlich jetzt in der Retro
area und ich möchte unbedingt mal diese
ganzen alten Spiele jetzt hier spielen
Clip auf Frank erzähl mir mal kurz wo
bin ich hier was mache ich hier also du
bist ja auf dem Stand der
retronatsmünsterland wir sind
eingetragener gemeinnütziger Verein wir
sammeln alte Automaten sind mittlerweile
zum Kulturgut wir retten die Sachen
sozusagen und bringen die auch die
jüngeren Leuten näher dass sie einfach
mal sichten wie so eine Technik früher
funktionierte und das ganze auch mal
irgendwann erhalten wird
[Musik]
der Automat ist von
1973 glaube ich das sieht so geil aus ja
es war einfach eine ganz andere
Medienlandschaft und wenn die Leute was
erleben wollten mussten die rausgehen
[Musik]
ja und für mich das absolute Highlight
ist hier der C64 der einer der ersten
Computer der erste und vor allem
beliebteste Heimcomputer den es in den
80er Jahren gab und es gibt neue Spiele
dazu ja genau es gibt sogar sehr viele
also ich bin nicht der einzige der neue
programmiert aber hier am Stand jetzt
zum Beispiel gibt es drei neue C64
Spiele von mir zu sehen
sich um Shotgun das ist ein Shooter für
vier Spieler man läuft in so einem
kleinen Labyrinth rum sammelt sich eine
Waffe ein und kann die anderen natürlich
damit abschießen
Spiel Nummer zwei was spielen wir hier
jetzt sie spielen heißt frogs und da
hüpfen mit Fröschen in einem Teich rum
und muss aufpassen dass man nicht ins
Wasser fällt kann die anderen aber auch
mit der Zunge ins Wasser stehen ich
glaube ich habe also gefühlt habe ich
das sogar schon mal gespielt ich bin mir
nicht sicher aber es kommt mir irgendwie
bekannt vor
jetzt aber die Spiele die durch die
Decke gehen im plug-tail Requiem das
zweite Abenteuer der Geschwister amicia
und Hugo vor dem Hintergrund der Pest
diesmal der rattenpest im Mittelalter
ein Überraschungshit der mit emotionaler
und erzieherischer Tiefe begeistert
bei Skull and Bones punktet nicht die
Geschichte sondern die endlosen Meere
die man als Pirat durchsegelt und sich
hochrauben und kämpfen kann in diesem
Jahr nicht dabei und damit ein fetter
Minuspunkt der Messe Nintendo die mit
splatoon 3 und Mario & Rabbids spark of
Hope zwei wahrscheinlich richtig
beliebte Spiele auf den Markt bringen
werden und auch Playstation und EA
stellen ihre neuen Spiele The Last of Us
part One und FIFA 23 nicht auf der Messe
vor und dennoch Highlights gibt es auf
der Messe einige
auch ich als nicht-gamerin muss sagen
die gamescom ist definitiv eine Reise
wert
ich bin ja auch eine nicht gamerin
übrigens Kira und ich finde es aber auch
total spannend muss ich sagen du bist
immer noch für uns auf der Gamescom es
gibt nämlich so viel zu erleben da
reichen nicht einen Tag da müssen uns
gleich mehrere sein und du bist mit
einer sogenannten Cosplayerin unterwegs
der Kai der fragt sich was das ist ganz
zehn mal erklären was es bedeutet und
was ihr da heute alles Spannendes erlebt
ja Cosplayer sind die Menschen die sich
hier auf der Messe eben als eine der
Action oder beziehungsweise Gaming
Figuren verkleiden und man sieht es hier
im Hintergrund wir sind nämlich gerade
im Cosplay village es laufen wirklich so
viele Besucher und Besucher hier rum die
sich wirklich so viel Mühe auch mit
ihren Kostümen gegeben haben und ich
habe heute morgen Morty besucht weil wir
wollten mal wissen wie ist das
eigentlich wenn man eben als ganz
normaler Mensch sich dann eben zu einer
Anime Figur verkleidet da haben wir sie
heute morgen in ihrem Hotelzimmer beim
fertigmachen besucht ich hoffe man sieht
die Bilder jetzt gerade schon insgesamt
zwei Stunden hat sie gebraucht um dann
eben zu ihrer Anime Figur zu werden und
jetzt steht sie hier fertig neben mir
bei mir sag mir mal einmal erklär mal
einmal dass die Faszination Cosplay was
ist das genau und warum macht ihr das
also Cosplay bedeutet du verkleidest
dich als ein Charakter egal ob es jetzt
Gaming ist oder ob es von einem Anime
kommt und die Faszination dahinter ist
einfach in diesen Charakter hinein zu
schlüpfen und sich da hineinzuversetzen
und am Ende dann so auszusehen wie
dieser Charakter und wenn einem das gut
gelingt dann freut man sich Wohnzimmer
total drüber du bist mir gestern ja
direkt aufgefallen als wir hier auf die
Messe gegangen sind und ich habe direkt
gesagt ich meine ich kenne mich in der
Gamingwelt wirklich gar nicht so gut aus
welcher Charakter bist du und was steht
so dafür genau ich bin asna von 200
online aus der dritten Staffel lsciation
und ja genau ich bin quasi so mit der
zweite Hauptcharakter die Freundin von
kirito und
in dem Anime geht es halt darum dass man
ein Spiel mit einer sozusagen die
abbrille spielt und dann in dieser Welt
drin ist und diese sind dann da drin
gefangen und kirito und Arsenal werden
sich halt gemeinsam kennen und ja ich
liebe den Charakter einfach und sie ist
super süß und ja einmal dein Outfit
zeigen man kann man mal end so zeigt
dass man einmal hier es ist wirklich
richtig detailreich du hast dir man hat
das gerade in den Bildern gesehen Du
hast Dir Kontaktlinsen extra gekauft
dafür dass man eben seine Augen also bzw
dass die Augen im Detail auch Stimmen
die Perücke die Teile vielleicht kannst
du dich auch einmal ein bisschen drehen
das ist schon wirklich viel viel Aufwand
erzähl uns einmal was gibst du für so
ein Outfit auch aus also für das Outfit
habe ich jetzt tatsächlich um die 200 €
insgesamt ausgegeben das ist sehr viel
auf jeden Fall aber man sieht am Ende
lohnt es sich wenn du wirklich einmal
alles zusammen hast und es zahlt sich
aus weil du hast das dann ja auch
theoretisch ein Leben lang wenn du es
behältst und ja mich macht das glücklich
und dein Freund ist auch hier mit dabei
den holen wir mal einmal mit dazu du
bist aber nicht verkleidet warum nicht
und ähm ja vielleicht mit demnächst also
es war geplant dass ich Tatsache den
Freund von asna Cosplay es wurde leider
doch ein bisschen zu spontan da das auch
bei ihr etwas länger gedauert hat habe
ich gesagt das wird nichts mehr dann
vielleicht nächstes Jahr
ich bin sehr gespannt auf jeden Fall
euch noch viel Spaß wie gesagt ihr seht
toll aus und ich bin wirklich
mittlerweile sehr begeistert ich habe
mir auch schon überlegt ob ich mich
nicht selbst demnächst doch noch mal als
Cosplay verkleide weil das wirklich ja
ich will ja immer neutral berichten aber
ich glaube man ich kann mir meine
Begeisterung gerade nicht verkneifen
nein unbedingt das wollen wir sehen wir
bitten darum Kira bisschen gruselig ist
durch die Halle und weiß nicht mehr was
echt ist und was nicht das ist schon
fasziniert danke Kira für den Moment
Menschen die leben diese Figuren da
wirklich ja das haben wir gerade
miterlebt vielen Dank für die Eindrücke
[Musik]